[Music]
tony dungy took exception to rich
mckay's admission that the nfl officials
are told to officiate the pass
interference rule differently on those
late game hail mary plays and this is
all becoming relevant as the nfl tries
to figure out how it's going to claw
back at the role that was passed back in
march chris to make pass interference
subject to replay review like any other
play that is subject to replay review
now they want to exempt certain
situations they want to have no
automatic challenges for past
interference they want it all to be
generated by the coaches challenge and
they want to get rid of it entirely when
it comes to hail mary plays and i think
one of the big problems here and we've
touched on this earlier in the show
we've spoken about it in the past the
idea that they're never going to be able
to objectively define what a hail mary
play is and if they try to bill
belichick is going to come up with a way
around it you can't say
x number of yards x number of time on
the clock x number of guys in the end
zone makes it a hail mary you can't do
it so here's my idea although i
reluctantly provide it because it kind
of helps rich mckay get out of his jam
i think they just need to give the
referee the power to say
when it is a hail mary to declare know
it when you see it that's a hail mary
play either during or after and the
referee has the power to turn off replay
review by saying that was a hail mary
and because we all know it when we see
it so let the referee decide that it is
a hail mary and then that's the play
that won't be subject to replay review
and and then they avoid the problem of
al riveron accidentally applying the
rule as written yeah well you're right
we do we all know uh what it looks like
when we see it right so i mean you're
not crazy there and you know even if
they put a time frame on it i mean
you know last 10 seconds last 15 seconds
i you know that might no not even that
not even that the the referee almost
like you know how the referee puts his
hand in the air when a guy shoots a
three-pointer right
in basketball i got you yeah when when
is
when the when the ball is thrown the
referee's been able to see the play he's
got that perfect vantage point behind
the quarterback he's seen the play
develop he knows the circumstances the
moment the ball comes out of the
quarterback's hand he throws his hand up
in the air to indicate that if the hail
mary rules are in effect and and and and
then you know it does it's not now look
all the other officials know it too
because they know in those situations
they're supposed to keep the flag deeper
in their pocket because rich mckay has
admitted they tell them that but i mean
that's that's where you turn off replay
review because if you try to tie it to a
time if you say 10 or 15 seconds you're
gonna have somebody try to throw a hail
mary with 16 seconds left oh yeah that's
why they can't use any of any and that's
i don't think we want to watch the end
of a game factoring in how bill
belichick is going to engineer his way
around the hail mary rules that takes
away from the enjoyment and the strategy
and the flow of the final minutes of a
game yeah well no you're right i mean
yes if there's going to be no penalties
called things guys coaches are going to
tinker with ways to cheat the system we
know that you know hey just to poke a
theory into what you're saying though so
this is what at least would bother me
there or at least i'm just one thing
unintended con consequence okay let's
just take like aaron rodgers at the end
of uh the arizona game a few years ago
not the touchdown hail mary but the one
when they were backed up in their own
end zone and he threw it down to like
the middle of the field now you know
originally that was a normal play call
right there wasn't like a hey guys hail
mary on two hail mary on two no he
called like 73 all go special half back
burst you know you know uh dummy snap
count on one right let's just say so
there wasn't a hail mary but now he
dances around the pocket nobody's open
he scrambles to his left and throws the
ball
to what it looks like now to a hail mary
type situation right when it really
wasn't a hail mary i guess that's where
i would worry about it a little bit so
now what are we going to do the
referee's going to go
but it's up to the referee it's no when
you see it because we as we were
watching it we knew what it was right
that's my point the officials know and
and if the officials on the field are
relaxing the past interference rules in
that setting they know too so you you
let's
do that any scenario that's all i'm
saying so here we are in the second
quarter and it's third and 25 and a guy
scrambles
and he just goes oh gosh i want to make
something happen he just throws the ball
down the field are we going to go oh
hail mary
no you can't do that so i'm just but
that but
that and you know what the fact that
we're having this conversation proves
that there should not be two different
sets of rules yes they shouldn't have to
worry about exempting replay review in
hail mary's settings
out there i'm not trying to challenge
you yeah but but the point is we are
highlighting the fact see the nfl in
their effort to clumsily claw back at
the law that's currently on the books
which is all past interference is
subject to replay review no matter the
circumstance no matter whether it's hail
mary or not hail mary to try to exempt
the hail mary rich mckay has admitted to
the world that they tell the officials
officiate these plays differently yeah
well how do they know when to officiate
it differently right right how do they
know when it's a play that devolves into
a hail mary on third and 25 so i i guess
my my point is if they're going to try
to carve those out then they they need
to just rely on the folks on the field
who activate these alternative rules
that they shouldn't be activating in the
first place and it just illustrates how
ridiculous it all is yeah well the
biggest thing that jumps out to me the
at least looks like to me with the past
interference you know uh new rules that
are they're being talked about and
playing this the nfl wants the you know
the burden off of them at the end of
these games they want the coaches or
somebody else but with the gambling like
you've said so many times mike and i
think you're spot on they don't want to
be the ones that have to make the
game-winning decision back in new york
city
quarterback number 32 on the chris sims
rank he's right after this
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports